I'm Nick Ryan I'm a music composer sound
designer artist and audio media
specialist my clients and my directors
often expect me to be conventional but
what they really want is a different
idea to everyone else I have to listen
really really carefully at the time most
people don't know how to listen and if
you learn how to listen
you'll be different to most people you
have to be able to care deeply about
what you do but not in isolation you
have to be able to collaborate with
other people and if you're collaborating
ultimately you have to be able to let go
of your work as part of the bigger
project
the first and most important thing was
to come up with a story and our previous
game Papa sangre who set in in Mexico in
a Mexican underworld and we decided to
set this one in space so we came up with
a story we came up with the location
then we started to edit levels and
create the actual structure of this this
this world and then we started to create
its inhabitants and be their monsters or
protagonists and then we started to
populate those levels and decide where
those different audio objects had to go
and then of course we had to play test
extensively one of the things we
encountered by in making an audio-only
game is that there's a huge amount of
subjective interpretation among our
players so it's quite important for us
to be sure that what we as game
designers think we're making is what our
players perceive it to be some of the
most significant decisions we made our
night jar were to firstly to build our
own game engine because nothing really
existed before this game to render 3d
sound in real time on a on a handheld
device and we could have we could have
used an existing engine but wouldn't
have really given us the flexibility
that we needed and in the long run would
have caused all sorts of other problems
such as licensing etcetera etcetera so
so we actually built our engine
ourselves so also when we decided to
make a game that was sound only we
realized we had to immerse the player in
a sound world that was believable and as
you know our own world is 3d its kind of
unremarkable we're used to listening in
3d but recordings are generally 2d
because they recorded with stereo
microphones and they don't really mimic
the way that we hear as humans so what
we used is a technique called binaural
recording and our game engine actually
renders sound in real time binaural E
and what that means is that we're
actually mimicking the way we hear as
humans
the reason we can tell with their sound
is not just to the left or the right of
us but also above all beneath us in
front of us or behind us is because
we've got two ears and our brains
actually make comparisons between what
our left ear hears my right ear hears
and it makes comparisons according to
volume time arrival and frequency and
when you put those three things together
you can actually create a 3d recording
and the easiest way to do that is to
place a microphone in each year and use
your head as the encoding tool if you
like the tools I use are some of some of
the tools I use a what everyone else
uses who's making sound logic audio and
Pro Tools but I also use lots of
specialist plugins lots especially
software to render sound in 3d I've got
one tool that's very good for placing
things behind you I've got one tool
that's very good for high-frequency
things and that's largely to do with the
shape of head that was used to make
their original algorithms I then use
various microphones including a dummy
head which has microphones in each year
and it looks like a crash crash test
dummy and we use that to actually make
make real recordings and in terms of the
game itself the game consists of
atmospheres which are loops objects
which move relative to you objects which
don't move relative to you which are
attached to your person like your
footsteps and also dialogue and dialogue
is is a vital component of this and we
were lucky enough to have Benedict
Cumberbatch as our main talent on this
the night John left you here as bait now
if the groove of the resolution are dead
and you will be - in minutes if you
don't get off this ship we had to make a
decision about whether to go for realism
over abstraction and what we discovered
was that we couldn't really go abstract
without exposition and it was a
fascinating process but
is what we ended up doing was trying to
use narrative narration became vital in
enabling our players to understand what
it was that they were listening to so
without any narration or any any sort of
narrative setup the interpretation our
players were open to was massive they
would perceive a completely different
space to each other so we had to set the
scene with fairly realistic sound sounds
that we have an innate recognition of
and an understanding of their physical
form we can actually visualize in our
imagination what object is making that
sound well once we've established that
we can then introduce providing there is
some explanation of it through narrative
we can actually introduce objects which
are more abstract and monsters for
example something in which we are we
expect to be abstract and we welcome
subjective interpretation of because
they then become much more frightening
the game did turn out mostly as we
expected it to but there are so-called
bugs which came from people's different
interpretations of what they were
hearing so we might have put in what we
thought was a monster and and and a
particular payer might have perceived it
to be a toilet flushing in the next-door
room rather than a monster crawling at
the wall you you know you never really
know so we had to extensively play test
this and then thun thun the actual
sounds as well in the absence of images
we can't help but hallucinate images in
our imagination as we do when we listen
to radio and that kind of age-old cliche
pitch is a better on radio stands with
the nightjar we you know we've said
jokingly that the night jar has the best
graphics engine in the world because
it's your imagination and what's
particularly exciting about being
nominated for the night jar for audio
achievement is that this is an audio
only
perience and that's that's quite a
unique proposition the thing that I'm
most proud of is that people who are
used to listening people who are blind
or visually impaired wrote to us and
told us that this was an incredibly
believable three-dimensional immersive
space and I would have expected they in
particular to have picked up on some of
the some of the the flaws in the sound
design and they they were very they were
very complimentary about it although
they did say that the games was far too
easy so we did have to make it harder
I'm also very proud of the fact that we
managed to keep our golden rule intact
the golden rule of all which was not to
have any visual representation of space
whatsoever and we were tempted
throughout the process to have some kind
of map but we we decided to be strict
with ourselves and now there is no
nothing to see you place your thumbs on
the screen you walk with your thumbs as
though they're your feet the interface
is intuitive and you can play the game
with your eyes closed